cuéntenos Cómo es la situación general
en América Latina y cuál es la tendencia
en materia de aborto Durante los últimos
años
Bueno muchísimas gracias por estar acá
en este día tan importante efectivamente
no América Latina y el Caribe se
caracteriza por ser una región que no
tiene las mismas provisiones legales
alrededor del acceso a derechos y
servicios de salud reproductiva en
particular en el aborto por un lado como
ya mencionabas pues está Colombia
Argentina Uruguay que permiten el aborto
sin restricciones hasta determinado
límite gestacional están otros los casos
más extremos como Nicaragua República
Dominicana El Salvador Honduras que lo
prohíben completamente y además
justamente Honduras no solamente prohíbe
totalmente el aborto sino que es el
único país en América Latina en donde el
anticoncepción oral de emergencia no
puede ser distribuida ni siquiera para
Víctimas de sobrevivientes de violación
sexual
y pues si bien digamos la mayoría de los
países de nuestra región penalizan de
una u otra forma el aborto Lo cierto es
que en cuanto a la tendencia sí ha
habido un muy importante en no solamente
en términos de los ajustes legales que
se han hechos como en Argentina en
Colombia en México sino a partir también
de la despenalización social del aborto
que se ha logrado por el trabajo de los
movimientos que de alguna forma es muy
importante y fuerte y poderoso lo que ha
pasado con la marea verde que nace en
Argentina y cómo ha impactado a la
región y esto nos ha permitido lograr
avances sumamente importantes como causa
justa acá en Colombia y ha impactado
incluso otros movimientos como el de
niñas nómadas que justamente Busca que
ninguna niña sea víctima de una
maternidad forzada
en estos países en los que hablamos en
los que el aborto todavía está prohibido
Cuáles son los principales problemas que
afrontan las personas gestantes
Sí allí
en El Salvador que es el caso que que
pues que quizás más conozco de cerca es
que enfrentan entonces un efecto que
causa la criminalización absoluta del
aborto y es que persigue no solamente a
las mujeres o a las personas con las
personas gestantes que buscan el
servicio sino que además persigue a
mujeres en situación de pobreza que
enfrentan cualquier tipo de emergencia
obstétrica incluso abortos espontáneos
partos extrahopitalarios y y esto además
causa No solamente eso unas condenas
además espantosas de 30 a 50 años de
prisión en este país por esta
persecución penal Pero además causa un
efecto miedo sobre el personal de salud
que entonces se enfrenta no solamente el
la posibilidad de ser criminalizados
también si no el estigma de proveer un
servicio incluso cuando la vida o la
salud de la mujer y la persona gestante
está en riesgo